on va voir la première est que cette
interview après on aura la vie bien sûr
de christine eric et jimmy on a voulu
lui demander pourquoi il la voyait
accepté de nous recevoir tous les trois
d'ailleurs de religions différentes
karim eric et moi au regard du premier
extrait
bonsoir monsieur le pen bonsoir alors
déjà première question pourquoi avoir
choisi nous recevoir
eric naulleau karim zéribi vous l'avez
demandé
vous recevrez tout le monde chez vous je
n'accepte pas toutes les habitations
mais il y en a qui sont la preuve
est ce que vous nous connaissez pas ce
que la série que là vous avez les trois
religions monothéistes ring je connais
peut-être mieux monsieur naulleau parce
que je les ai rencontrés à plusieurs
reprises dans des émissions mais la
télévision or en main tous les gens
présents maintenant ça desquels le livre
sur le fn qui est sorti là dernièrement
on a la jeune fille la femme voilà qui
l'a lequel il y en a plusieurs mais mme
sophie renseignements tél ah oui elle
aborde des sujets très très différent
commençant par le plus anecdotique
elle décrit les turpitudes qui aurait
lieu jaune à la clé un lieu de votre
parti notamment des turpitudes de sexuel
guédé il ya des passages extrêmement
explicite commençons par l'anecdotique
qu'est ce que vous répondez libre et
madame ont-elles est resté trente ans
voilà au front national
elle a donc si je comprends bien d'après
ses aveux participer à ces diableries
oui voilà attendu comme j étais pas
invité alors madame honte elle ne m'a
pas fait cet honneur et je constate
qu'elle est partie avec monsieur
philippe oh et puis en plus elle s'est
détachée de monsieur philippot
elle a une certaine tendance à
l'individualisme vous n'êtes pas au
courant non je n'ai pas vu au front
national de spectacles turpides
particulier non
au départ je voulais pas vous rencontrer
parce que pour moi dans ma tête voilà
vous étiez antisémite vous étiez massive
était homophobe
est ce que vous êtes raciste mais
n'aurait pourquoi toute ma vie j'ai
prouvé que je ne l'étais pas un exemple
le premier j'ai été le premier à
présenter la candidature d'un arabe à la
députation à paris en 1957 détendent
amis
de toutes les couleurs de les religions
aller droit au but deux phrases que vous
avez dit je ne dis pas que les chambres
à gaz n'ont pas existé mais je crois que
c'est un point de détail de l'histoire
de deuxième guerre mondiale
j'ai été incroyablement poursuivis et
condamnés de ce chef n'est ce pas par
conséquent je ne vais pas reprendre ce
risque l'intelligence des lecteurs aura
rétabli la réalité d'elle-même ce pas ok
vous voulez par étonne je l'aide que
vous faites c'est toujours deuxième
phrase jean marie le pen oui je crois
l'inégalité des races
est ce à dire qu'il n'ya pas une race
humaine mais que ne sait dans les rafles
marché même s'il ya des inégalités mais
écoutez quand on a quand on est sorti du
16e arrondissement et qu'on n'était pas
mon cas et qu'on a traîné ses bottes un
peu partout dans le monde on se rend
bien compte d'une chose c'est que les la
catégorie qu'on qualifie de race est
évident qu'elles ne sont pas égales en
capacité il ya là qui nage plus vite il
y en a qui courent plus vite il y en a
qui pensent plus vite c'est ça ne me
choque pas du tout qu'il en soit ainsi
si je veux avoir ma statue je vais voir
plutôt un sculpteur cas cuisinier voilà
c'est tout on voit que vous êtes cravate
orange aujourd'hui est ce que vous vous
considérez comme gilet jaune
je ne suis pas à gilet jaune et je
trouve que c'est un mouvement spontané
étonnant par sa naissance d'abord parce
que très vite les la manifestation a
pris des proportions considérables
ces gens là ne pense pas la même chose
sur la plupart des problèmes mais ils
ont en commun c'est le gilet jaune et
j'ai dit le vrai chef des mouvements
c'est le gilet est vrai il ne pense pas
malheureusement et ne parle pas on sait
bien que les gens de l'extrême gauche
sont sont ceux qui se crée les problèmes
dans la manifestation on parle de gens
d'extrême tient pas à des gens de
l'extrême dalton demandent si tu
considères 1 c'est ce que disent
certains gilet jaune ils disent qu'il ya
dieye aval il ya déjà des casseurs qui
ont intégré mouvement des jeunes des
casseurs d'extrême droite n'ont qu'une
seule fois lors de l'ag jaune je crois
pas du tout il n'existe aucun mouvement
radical d'extrême droit n'existe pas en
france il n'y a aucun mouvement radical
d'extrême orient connaît pas ça n'existe
tous les cas je ne connais pas ça mais
aussi de vous en connaissant les
qualités que nous explorons les ces
données non on voit bien d'ailleurs que
la volonté des casseurs anticapitaliste
elle est très marquée ils s'attaquent
eux maison de de luxe était en principe
nous sommes dans une république dont la
devise est liberté égalité fraternité
par conséquent les idées cours cassel
quand même dédié les ondes est adoptée
des idées portées par certaines
personnalités l'extrême droite qui écrit
at il d'étonnant à cela
je n'ai pas été au coeur de ces
histoires ni même aux marges alors jean
marie le pen on va faire un peu
d'exercice
je vais vous montrer des photos vous
allez dire si ses personnages pour vous
son rat sera ça veut dire angoissant
houdart cas c'est à dire qu'ici ils sont
sympathiques aux rats sera ou dark à nyc
nicolas sarkozy il est rapide et dark à
ce sympathique
oui donc dark heart au sympathique
monarque à françois hollande
saad adversaires politiques je ne trouve
pas particulièrement sympathique mais il
n'est pas non plus quand y cueillir
monte antipathique
donc il émit d'arcade en sera autrement
dit je suis beaucoup plus nuancée que
votre questionnaire emmanuel macron à à
lui la regardera sera à l'air plus
intéressant pour vous comme cas par cas
il n'est pas fondamentalement
d'antipathie qu vous aimez tout le monde
est plus haut niveau jean marie le pen
son art car il est plus sympathique
qu'angoissant oui pour tous les maliens
d'arca d'arc à bombay sont barca alors
pour vous quel a été le meilleur que je
peux dire belkin pour vous pour vous le
moment une bonne qualité le meilleur
président des trois ou moins mauvais
houle a compliqué un jeu pour choisir un
maître sarko je me sentais sarko jean
mario peigne d'art qu'aura sera jean luc
mélenchon écoutez si on peut avoir une
certaine sympathie pour ses adversaires
politiques
monsieur mélenchon fait partie de ces
gens donc dar k
oui ils sont tout ouïe donald trump
d'art qu'aura sait qui c'est donald
trump le pluton piste oui je ne connais
pas se tromper mais je trouve son action
assez positive donc il est d'art car il
ya personne qui rentre alors bernard
tapie
burke a c'est le premier ouais ouais je
n'ai pas de sympathie pour mieux pour
bernard tapie qui qui me le rend bien je
crois par conséquent ça sera oui et
c'est qui ça monsieur le pen
cet appel est très sympathique d'arca
très un bon français c'est bon un bon
français en beauté florian philippot
passera vous l'aimez pas vous n'attendez
pas que je trouve sympathique parce que
lui aussi il a raconté que je l'avait
injuriée de nombreuses reprises menace
et il n'a jamais incapable de citer une
seule injures mais le souci ce n'est que
j'ai j'ai parlé un jour de son entourage
de mignon on ne s'était pas mais c'était
par quatre terribles et je n'ai pas été
personnellement trahi par filippo c'est
le mouvement qu'il a été pas moi
dernière photo jean-marie le pen c'est
marine d'arcachon
j'aime bien marine c'est votre fils
normal nous en aurions fait penser
qu'elle plus de chances de devenir
présidente marine ou marion maréchal-le
pen c'est marine parce que marion semble
s'être détachée de la politique pour
vous à la quitter la vie politique à
c'est elle qui l'a décidé elle fait
autre chose trois dernières questions
vous me répondez par oui ou par non
juste le nom est ce que vous êtes
raciste non est ce que vous êtes
homophobe
non est ce que vous aimez l'équipe de
france de football
oui quant à eux gagnent
ça dans sa configuration actuelle ah oui
est ce qu'elle est voilà ce sont des
règles et dernier le sélectionneur
respecte la loi et respectent les règles
dernière question est ce que vous êtes
vraiment aux relations avec votre fille
est ce que ça se passe bien avec marine
oui ma foi oui de là j'attends son
retour les parties à la réunion j'aurais
peut-être l'occasion de au cours de la
campagne européenne de me trouver avec
elle dans un meeting
si vous avez un regret dans votre
parcours politique
quel serait-il pas avoir été candidat à
la présidence
au moment où j'ai poussé tixier
vignancour à l'être en 65
ça c'est pour le regret mais est-ce que
vous avez un remords non j'ai pas drogba
aucun remords non j'ai eu une vie droite
je suis un combattant à visage découvert
je ne crois pas je n'ai pas à me
reprocher qu'est ce qu'on peut appeler
une saloperie dont cas on peut retrouver
peut-être viril brutale je conjure le
crois pas l'air et l'image qui a été
donnée de jean marie le pen ne
correspond pas du tout ni à son passé ni
à son présent né à son futur